[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
willy aybar autochtone ceci mise à mal
depuis cinq semaines j'ai envie nous par
une nouvelle répartition des médias
sociaux et vous allaitez taux ne sera
pas la raison pour laquelle vous pensez
que je peux en parler on parle du
retrait de permis d'une compagnie de
recyclage de matériaux de construction à
cannes s attaquer le problème grec et en
retirer le permis plus qu'il ne
respectait pas les règles entourant la
loi sur l'environnement
le propriétaire décidant de lui
contester l'addition en tant qu il est
mort sur tous les corps morts donc ce
n'est pas à la province de données la
plus permis cette année avec la
communauté la communauté elle aussi on
est pragmatique par rapport à la
pratique compagne de là mais bien sûr
qui veut nettoyer si on abandonne le
site on me retire le permis ça fait
quand même pas la compagnie de se
réajuster donc vous imaginez la boîte de
pandore par rapport à la loi sur les
délits réserve des droits ancestraux
version noire ce sera d'avoir confisqué
âge ça compte ça concerne quand même
beaucoup d'enjeu et aussi parce que par
le passé quand on voyait des compagnies
ou même l'armée canadienne enterré des
produits chimiques sur lesquels les
terres de réserve des communautés
autochtones et enfin disparaître la
croix sur la carte
hélas les communautés sont pris à deux
fois savoir où se trouvent les matières
dangereuses
c'est un enjeu imbroglio qui concerne
quand même beaucoup de paliers du
gouvernement mais c'est pas pour ça que
je voulais vous en parler ma
problématique à moi m'a vraiment ici
toute la consommation tant les
commentaires de la nouvelle idéologie du
noble sauvage 9 le sauvage à ne pas
utiliser au quotidien mais ça m'énerve
le sauvage c'est un concept à la
littérature et même en récit d'aventuré
qui est très très puissant et là ça
remonte quand même à 15 ans qu'on a
entendues ou
on a pu lire les premiers récits
justement de l'exploration des amériques
on ne peut en lire aussi avec jacques
cartier par exemple quand il a exploré
l'amérique du nord québec
le concept du noble sauvage vient du
concept judéo-chrétien que quand adam et
eve ont croqué la pomme
ils ont su ce qu'était le péché originel
ils ont su qu'ils étaient nuls et donc
on a perdu le parent est le paradis
perdu d'ailleurs qui a été identique
soit comme l'amérique parce que les
premiers contacts qui se sont fait que
les européens ont été de voir des
autochtones flambant nu qui avait promis
de leur nullité de leur sexualité des
traits en harmonie avec la nature donc
virologie de l'homme proche de la nature
de l'homme sauvage est venu très
fortement teinté justement la
littérature les fines et continue encore
à ce jour
parce que dans les commentaires on dit à
son pack si proches que ça de la nature
en se basant sur le comportement de 28,6
le premier le concept de l'aider sauvage
ou du noble sa rage si bien mettre un
idéal qui soutient l'identité autochtone
et là je donne un exemple
c'est comme si être effectué par la
maison par l'adn nous étions plus
proches de la nature nous étions plus en
harmonie comme si c'était dans le fond
un héritage biologique et je donne un
exemple
pocahontas et part avec un [ __ ] laveur
qui sont de grandes joies aussi avec
avatar qui continue dans l'espace ce
concept noble sauvage la problématique
autour d'autun sectionné ce ne sont pas
les humains en tant qu'être biologique
ue ce rapprochement avec la nature
fillon ce rapprochement avec la culture
qui veut protéger la terre mère c'est
vraiment la culture c'est ce qui est
important du message qui nous a été
transmis en venant au monde nous sommes
pas des êtres peur et
[Musique]
et avec un reflex incréé sec de protéger
la nature
nous nous faisons renseigner est
d'ailleurs une des grandes
problématiques autour de société la
déconnexion territoire a amené de
nouveaux concepts et s'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ont suivi de la
colonisation les pensionnats la mise en
réserve les sixties coupe et le lien
culturel est très déconnecté
cependant ce lien existe encore très
fortement à beaucoup de communautés et
de plus en plus pour réparer pour
réconcilier justement les pratiques des
fêtes envers les communautés autochtones
eh bien on reconnaît que nos jeunes avec
la nature avec leurs pratiques
traditionnelles et en plus on transmet
ses savoirs là à des non autochtones
parce que ce ne seront pas des savoirs
d'automne ce sont des savoirs humains
qui ont été portées par l'histoire par
les communautés autochtones mais de
mettre le poids idéologique de un
autochtone c'est pur et c'est naturel
c'est le guen problématique c'est que
tous les humains devraient être prêts
naturel humain devrait faire attention
aux territoires
elle n'a lequel ils habitent mais encore
aujourd'hui les systèmes économiques les
systèmes culturels
la colonisation est vraiment transformé
le paysage et l'allèle le lien pour peu
à voir avec les victoires donc en
essayant de perpétuer cette espèce
d'image de on veut vraiment en lui dans
cet homme si on n'est pas comme ça on
est pas des autochtones
alors que on peut le voir comme au
québec cause 2 unis les individus sont
tous très différentes et la culture et
pas nécessairement un briquet et les
perspectives et elle est encouragée
donc merci à tous ceux qui dans les
commentaires on justement 10 ans et
rappelle aux gens mais on peut pas juger
une communauté par les actions de
quelques uns de ses membres et je pense
que sinon ça ferait une finalité où les
êtres humains or américains qui sont
produits autochtones ne peuvent vivre en
harmonie avec la nature ce qui est faux
et ce qui n'est pas désirable
puisque 30 ans à vouloir partager nos
savoirs et à pouvoir les échanges donc
je me serais une belle semaine n'hésitez
pas à partager cette vidéo et n'hésitez
pas non plus à nous envoyer des
questions de suggestions bretons mènent